SPEAKER: Alan
Burdick is a writer
for "The New Yorker,"
"Out of Eden--
an Odyssey of
Ecological Invasion"
was his last book, which was a
National Book Award finalist.
And today he's going
to talk about--
maybe one thing he
should talk about
is why people don't
wear watches anymore.
There's a lot of aspects
of time which most of us
probably never thought
of, like how do we
know what the correct time is?
And Alan actually
went to the source,
which is Paris, where every
month they look at all--
ALAN BURDICK: Don't tell--
don't give it away.
SPEAKER: OK.
He'll tell you how
it really works out.
He also spent-- how long, a
month, six weeks in the Arctic?
ALAN BURDICK: Just two weeks.
SPEAKER: --two
weeks in the Arctic,
where it's 24 hours a day.
And in order to give him
more time and me less,
I'm going to turn it
over to Mr. Burdick now.
Let's have a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN BURDICK: Thank you.
Thank you, Bob.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody,
for turning out.
Thank you wherever you
may be for tuning in.
Yes, so I think
before I dive in,
I will give you just
a very quick overview
of what this book is all about.
It started a few
years ago with what
I realize now were some pretty
broad and naive questions.
I had read a fair amount
about space time and Einstein
and Hawking and all of that.
But it always seemed to
me that that never really
had a whole lot to do
with the kind of time
that I inhabit from
day to day and minute
to minute, like why
does that stoplight
seem to be taking so long?
And how do I know, right?
And it really does seem
like time speeds up
when I'm having fun,
but why is that?
And why am I waking up
every day at exactly 4:27
AM, day after day,
without an alarm clock?
It seemed like there was
some kind of a time--
some sort of time in
me and in my cells that
is somehow different
from the time
out there, whatever
out there is.
And what is that?
And where does it come from?
There's no physics in the book.
There's virtually
no philosophy there.
I mean, there are volumes
on the philosophy of time,
and I just skipped all of that.
And this is really a series
of kind of explorations
and conversations
with psychologists
and neuroscientists
and biologists.
And I focus on very
tangible experiments
and, to a certain extent,
my own experience.
Because when we
talk about time, it
can seem really slippery
and really abstract.
But at the same time, it is this
very intimate, personal thing.
And it seems to kind
of suffuse everything.
And that's what I
wanted to get at,
and I wanted to try to make
the experience, the reading
experience, as kind of tactile
and as immediate as possible.
So out I go into the
world of scientists
with my naive question,
which is, so what is time?
And pretty much to a one they
would reply immediately, well,
what do you mean by time?
And it turns out that
what we call time--
time is basically
a big umbrella word
that we use to describe a
lot of discrete experiences
that we don't
typically parse out.
But very quickly, the
perception of time
includes things
like your ability
to know what time it is
right now without a clock;
your understanding that
there is a past and a present
and a future, and they kind
of go in different directions;
your ability to understand
how long an event lasts,
whether that's a stoplight
or your innate ability
to understand that three seconds
is actually longer than one
second or even 2 and 1/2
seconds without counting it out,
which is actually something that
rats and pigeons can do also.
And all of this may
seem kind of obvious,
but to a kid coming into the
world all of these experiences
are revelations.
A lot of developmental
psychology in the last 50
years, starting with Piaget,
has shown that these experiences
come online at different
ages, and they kind of
build up into layers.
So you could have--
by three years old,
a kid can pretty well
speak without error in both
the past and the present tense.
But it's not until they're
about four years old
that they understand
the difference
between before and after.
So you can ask four or
five-year-old Jane in January
which is going to come first--
July, when your birthday
is, or Christmas?
And she'll say
Christmas because she
hasn't made the distinction
between proximity and next--
what's next in the
forward direction.
And underneath all of
that, all those kind
of psychological
experiences, there's
this kind of time
that's really hardwired
into all of our cells,
and that's circadian time.
We have these circadian
clocks throughout our bodies,
and they quite firmly
run our physiology
over a pretty strict
24-hour cycle.
But for our purposes
here, I'm actually
going to skip all of that.
And I want to focus on
just really one aspect
of what we call time, and
that is our experience of now.
And again, not space time
or anything, but this now
that maybe you feel
when you wake up
in the middle of
the night and it's
kind of coming at you--
now, now, this now that's
right here in
front of your face.
What is that?
And it turns out
this is actually
a question that has been
bugging humans for a long time
and maybe even since
humans started thinking.
Plato, Zeno,
Aristotle, they thought
about the question of
now in terms of physics,
and they really tied
themselves into knots.
Is the present some kind
of indivisible instant,
a dimensionless sliver between
the past and the future,
or does now have some
kind of duration?
And if it has a duration,
can we measure it?
But wait, if it has a
duration, can we chop it up
into smaller subdivisions?
And what's in between
those subdivisions?
And is this always the same
now, or does it keep changing?
And if it changes,
when does it change?
So you could kind of go
around for 3,000 years
in circles trying to
figure that stuff out.
And it gets existential
really quickly.
So how do I know that I am
the same individual that I
was a minute ago or
last week or last year?
How do I change and yet kind
of remain continuously me?
There's actually an
ancient Greek play
that addresses this
and sort of plays out
like a Laurel and Hardy skit.
And one guy goes
up to another guy
that he's lent some
money to and he says,
yeah, I'd like my money back.
And the second guy says, oh, but
you didn't borrow that from me.
I'm no longer the same
person I was then,
anymore than a pile of stones
from which we added and removed
some pebbles is the
same pile of stones.
At which point the first guy
hits that guy in the face.
And that guy says,
why did you do that?
And the first guy says, who me?
[LAUGHTER]
Then we move forward to
about the fourth century
and a theologian named
St. Augustine appears.
And Augustine has written
a book of his own.
It's called "The Confessions."
And it's this kind of
combination of autobiography
and an extended
meditation on God
and creation and
especially time.
And what he essentially
does is move the discussion
of what is now,
what is the present,
from physics pretty squarely
into the realm of what
we would call today psychology.
And he talks a lot about time.
But again, it's important to
note that what he means by time
is quite specifically
the present--
now.
And he describes an experience.
He's talking.
He's reading something.
And these syllables are kind
of coming out of him one
after another.
And at some point he realizes,
oh, hey, one of those syllables
is twice as long as one of the
other syllables that I spoke.
He says, well, but
how do I know that?
How did I measure that?
Did I measure both
of those syllables
together in the past tense?
How do you measure
something in a past tense
that doesn't exist anymore?
Well, then I must measure
them in the present tense.
But how do I measure a
duration before it's over?
And he kind of stirs
that around for a while.
And he comes up with an insight
that is really still with us
today.
And he says, OK, past,
present, future--
well, the past doesn't really
exist except in our mind
and as memory.
And the future doesn't really
exist yet except in our mind
in terms of expectation.
So all we have is the present.
And he says, so we don't
really have three tenses.
We really only
have one or, if you
will, three flavors of one,
three flavors of the present,
which he describes like this--
the present of past
things, which is memory;
the present of present
things, which is attention;
and the present of future
things, which is expectation.
And the upshot is that
all of these presents
exist only in our mind.
That is the temporal experience.
It's in the mind.
And he's really
into this because he
is interested in
questions of the soul.
And for him, the present is
the container of the soul.
But he goes back to thinking
about this sentence.
And these syllables are
coming out one after another.
And his mind is reaching
forward into the future
to kind of figure out
what's going to come next.
And it's sort of stretching
back into the past
to try to remember
what he's already said
so he doesn't say it again.
And he says, we're stretched
between memory and expectation.
And he says, the vital
energy of what I am doing
is in tension between the two.
And that's you.
That's us-- this tension
spread across the now.
And he says time is
nothing other than tension.
And I would be very surprised
if time is not tension
of consciousness itself.
And I love the phrase.
But what I really love is this
idea that now isn't actually
the present, isn't
actually some stuff.
It's actually a volume.
He compares it to a volume that
is contained by consciousness.
Which is to say that
now, the present,
is the thing-- this is
the definition of it.
Now is the thing that our
consciousness contains.
And that sounds weird.
It comes up centuries later.
And it comes basically
straight out of the mouth
of William James--
1890, William James,
Harvard psychologist,
brother of Henry James.
He's written a big
book, a textbook called
"Principles of Psychology,"
which is a classic almost as
soon as it comes out.
And James is thinking
back over some discoveries
that have been made in
physiology over the past 50
years.
And one of the things that's
happening in the 19th century
is that clocks are
getting better and better.
And they can access
now not just seconds,
but tenths of seconds
and hundredths of seconds
and even thousandths of seconds.
And when you start looking
at time scales like that,
you discover a lot of things,
such as the speed of thought
is not actually finite.
So it was thought that
if I think, OK, I'm
going to raise my hand now,
that that thought process is
instantaneous.
But along comes in the
1850s a German physiologist
who gets some
subjects and he starts
zapping them on their
bodies very lightly
with an electric shock.
So he zaps you on your toe.
That's now.
And he says, OK, move your
head when you feel this.
And he does this all
around your body.
And it turns out
there's actually
a delay between when you
feel it and when you respond.
It's like a tenth of a second.
And he begins to realize,
oh, our nerves are
a lot like telegraph
cables, which, by the way,
are kind of popping up
everywhere in the 19th century.
And we know that telegraphic
cables have delays in them.
That's sort of inherent.
And, well, so our nerves, our
neurons do the same thing.
And the transmission, basically
the perception of when now is,
takes a little bit
of time to process.
And he says the time between
experiencing a stimulus
and becoming aware of it,
and the time for the brain
to go about the process
of perceiving and willing
and responding, takes
about a tenth of a second.
So he suddenly,
like, put a number--
he's, like, quantified what
you might call consciousness.
And German
physiologists, the world
of experimental psychology,
is just getting going.
And their whole mandate
is to basically come up
with an exact description
of consciousness.
And this is their way in.
And they set up all
these great experiments
to figure out basically
how long now is.
Because if they can figure
out how long now is,
they can figure out basically
how big our consciousness is.
And so the experiments
are things like,
OK, I'll give you two
quick sparks in a row--
flick, flick.
How close together
can I put them
and have you still perceive
them as distinct events?
And the answer is like 50
milliseconds, 20th of a second.
It's pretty close.
Or say I tap out of
rhythm, like this.
[TAPPING]
How long can I stretch that
out, and how fast or how slow
can I make it, and how many
beats can I throw in there
and have you still experience
that rhythm as a whole rhythm
and not kind of lose
sight of the whole thing?
And they come up with
all sorts of numbers
for the length of the
present, because pretty much
every different way
you measure it is going
to give you a different number.
It's a tenth of a second.
It's 2/100 of a second.
It's three seconds long
or five seconds long.
Somebody describes it as
the length of a sentence--
the length of a spoken sentence.
And so James comes along and
he's like, forget all of that.
You guys, that is like
microscopic psychology.
That's what he calls it.
Let's just get back to
our normal experience,
that feeling that I'm having as
I'm laying awake at night that
now is kind of coming
at me in waves,
in these kind of
discrete moments.
And he goes back
really to Augustine,
and he thinks about the past
and the present and the future.
And he says, really none
of those are helpful.
But this fourth
thing, which I'm going
to call the specious present,
that's where all the action is.
And he says the specious
present is basically
a very short duration.
Let's not get bogged
down in numbers.
But it has a beginning,
and it has an end.
And there's room in
there to have a thought
or to notice that, oh, hey,
that's a sparrow flying
across the yard--
not like big thoughts,
just, like, enough.
And he comes up with
all sorts of metaphors
for the specious present.
It's like a boat.
Or it's a waterfall.
Or it's a length of rope.
And he calls it
the short duration
"of which we are immediately
and incessantly sensible."
So once again, he is
basically defining now.
He's defining the present as the
container of our consciousness,
the short duration of
which we are immediately
and incessantly and sensible.
And there had been some
thinking going on at the time
that we, as humans, are
actually capable of perceiving
empty moments of time.
And that time is actually
some kind of stuff out there.
That we might even have
sensors in our ears,
and we can pick it
up as it comes at us.
And James is like,
no, no, no, look,
here I am lying awake at
night, and the moments
are coming at me--
now, now, now.
And even if there's nothing
really going on in there,
if you look close,
if I look close,
there is stuff going on there.
And what's going on
there is my thoughts.
And even if I'm not
thinking any thoughts,
maybe it's just like the
colored lights behind my eyelids
that flicker around.
And it's that change,
it's that slight change
of thought, that
slight change of color
that we perceive as this
passing moment, right?
And so it's like--
in his view now is basically
our mind listening to itself,
observing itself work.
And he goes on to say, you know
what that means is basically
now, the present, this very
short thing called the present,
is undefined without
our mind to fill it.
And in fact, it's our mind
that gives rise to it.
It's not like a moment,
a present moment,
is sort of out there
waiting for us to receive.
We're actually conjuring it.
He says we tell
it off in pulses.
We say now, now, now.
Or we count-- more, more,
more as we feel it bud.
And time seems to
flow in discrete units
not because we perceive
units of empty time,
but because each of our acts
of perception is discrete.
Now arises again and again
just because we say now
again and again.
James calls the present, this
moment, a synthetic datum.
It's not experienced as
much as manufactured.
And that's what I want to talk
about for the rest of the time
here, this idea that now isn't
really instantly received.
It's actually
manufactured by us.
And because it's
manufactured by us,
it takes some time to process.
Now is not instantaneous.
And this is something
that we see playing out
both in all of our devices and
in our bodies and in our minds.
Does somebody have a watch or
a smartphone with a time on it?
What can you tell me?
AUDIENCE: 12:25.
ALAN BURDICK: 12:25.
OK.
So that exchange
that we just had
is probably the most
fundamental transaction
in the living world.
We are synchronizing, right?
We're coming to an
agreement about what now is.
You're telling me when
now is, and now I know.
And either it agrees
with me or it doesn't.
But the whole point
of that conversation
is for us to agree, right?
And this is probably a good
moment to stop very quickly
and talk about clocks.
So a clock does at
least two things.
It can be a timer.
It can keep track of how
much time has gone by
or is still to come.
So it can look
kind of like this.
Or if you want to
be a little bit more
fancy and a little more
precise, it can look like that.
But a clock, if you do this
and add some numbers to it,
you're adding a whole new
layer of meaning, right?
Because it matters
where you are now.
That where you are at
3:00 is not actually
the same now is where you
are at 9:00, for instance.
And what this is
telling you, what
this stopwatch, this clock,
is telling you is the time.
That is to say,
when now is, right?
Heidegger said that the
whole point of a clock
is to determine the
specific fixing of the now.
And here's the thing--
a clock for this purpose is
totally useless by itself.
Now, in this sense,
only means something
if it's in relation to
the now on another clock.
So if I look at the
clock and it says noon,
well, that means a
couple of things maybe.
It means-- well, it could be the
middle of the solar day, right?
Noon is the middle
of the solar day.
The solar day is a clock.
It's a 24-hour clock
that's beat out
by the rotation of the Earth.
That's a clock.
Or maybe I'm looking
and it's noon
and I'm thinking, oh, my gosh,
I'm talking at Google at noon.
And everybody there is
going to have a watch,
and they're thinking, well,
he should really be here now.
Where is he, right?
So my now, my clock,
my thinking about now
is really only useful if
somebody else is, too.
And so what time
is it right now?
Tell me again.
AUDIENCE: 12:27.
ALAN BURDICK: Does anybody here
have a watch or clock that does
not have that same time on it?
What does yours say?
AUDIENCE: 12:29.
ALAN BURDICK: OK, you, sir,
are totally odd, right?
Everybody else here,
like, we're all
totally on the same
page about when now is.
Our clocks are
talking to each other.
They're getting along.
They're chatting really nicely.
And we're all agreeing
about when now is.
And that's one thing
to take away here
is that the fixing of the now,
as Heidegger described it,
is actually a process.
It's a conversation among clocks
agreeing about when now is.
It's a convention, in a sense.
So now you might begin to wonder
well, how is it that all of us,
all the rest of us,
actually have the same time
on our watches
and on our clocks?
And for that matter,
how do we actually
know that that is
the right time?
Well, it's because
all of our devices
are referencing some
other clock further
up the stream that is
more accurate than ours
and that we are
synchronizing to.
And of course that one,
because you can't just
have one clock by
itself, is referencing
some even more accurate
clock further up the chain.
It's like it's clocks
all the way up.
But what is at the top?
Let's find out.
So once upon a time, the
best clock in the world,
or the best clock in
your neighborhood,
you found at the
local observatory.
There was an
astronomer in there.
He looked at the
motion of the stars,
and he figured out
when solar noon was--
I mean, exactly,
like, solar noon.
And that's really important.
And he would then distribute
that information locally.
And at the beginning,
for a while
the Greenwich Royal Observatory
was the most accurate--
had the most accurate
clock in the world.
And people from town
literally would show up,
and they would
knock on his door.
And they would be
like, what time is it?
Can I just like to check
my watch with your watch?
And this started to happen
so often that he really
got annoyed.
And so the town hired
somebody, hired a guy
to do this once a day.
And he would go over there
and he'd get the time.
And then he would
wander through town.
And if you wanted
to check your watch,
you would pay him a
little bit of money
and you would synchronize
to him and indirectly
to the observatory.
And so time actually starts
to become a commodity, right?
And you start to
see time services.
And this all takes a
little bit of time.
It takes time for that guy to
go there and then come around
to you.
Maybe you want your
time a little faster.
Well, telegraphs
come along, and they
make it possible
for observatories
to start kind of piping the time
out much more quickly and much
more often during the day.
And then this is really
happening all across Europe.
So all of these
observatories are
spreading their
interpretations of when
now is, when solar noon is.
And what you get is a
landscape that looks like this.
I don't know if you
can see it here.
I'll zoom in.
So it's noon in Washington.
It's 16 minutes after
1:00 in Georgetown.
It's 26 minutes after
12:00 in Santiago.
What you notice is
nobody's on the hour.
And there's all these tiny
little times everywhere.
Here's a similar clock.
This was made-- this
drawing was made in 1851.
And it represents the various
local times in Europe.
That other one is from 1862.
So this is kind of a problem,
especially if you're a railroad
and you want your passengers,
your human beings,
to be able to understand
your train schedule
and to make their
train connections.
If you're going to Vienna
where there's one local time,
and you're going to Paris where
there's another local time,
and there are, like, eight
local times in between
and you have to make
a train connection,
it's a serious headache.
And even worse, if
you're a switch engineer
and you need to know
exactly when to switch
the switch on the tracks so
that those two trains don't
come crashing into
each other, you really
better know when now is.
And you better be right.
So that's kind of
the moment when
the world gets
together and says,
let's just have 24 time zones.
And that's a whole
other discussion
that I won't get into.
But the point of it is--
so we are now getting our--
we're getting our time
not from an observatory.
We are getting our
time from a clock
either in Maryland
or in Colorado.
And these are not observatories.
What they do there is-- and this
is their term-- they "realize"
seconds.
Now, there are two
kinds of seconds.
There's the old kind of second,
where if you take the solar day
and you divide it up into 86,400
parts, you have one second.
But in the '50s and
'60s, physicists
realize, oh, we can get
seconds another way.
We could get an
isotope of cesium
and watch it vibrate
9 billion-plus times.
And it's basically
exactly the same as that.
And the great thing about
doing it that way is we
get the same exact second,
second after second.
It's always the same.
Which isn't actually
true of the other one,
because the Earth is
actually slowing down.
So that second is
really not so reliable.
So there are these atomic
clocks that we have
in Maryland and in Colorado.
And they are realizing seconds.
And then they take
their seconds.
And they take 86,400 of
them and they stack them up.
And then they have
the 24-hour day.
And at any point in that
day, your clock or your phone
can actually tap in and find
out what time it is right now.
And they actually get pinged
like 13 billion times a day
from clocks and devices wanting
to know what time it is.
But of course, I said there's
one atomic clock there.
But there's not really
one atomic clock
in each of those places.
They actually have
ensembles of clocks,
because you can't rely
on just one clock.
So they sort of have
a bunch, and they
take an average
of all the seconds
to get you a very
good average second.
And then they
actually compare that
to an even more accurate
clock that involves
transitions of rubidium.
It's called a rubidium fountain.
And so that gives
them some modicum
of reliability and accuracy.
And meanwhile, we're doing
this in the United States.
France is doing the same thing.
England, they've got their
own national clocks--
national time labs
around the world,
all realizing their own seconds.
And needless to
say, none of them
agree exactly with another.
So we have over us
an even bigger time
that we all synchronize to.
And this time is called
Universal Coordinated Time,
or UTC.
And when this concept
was thought up,
the French actually wanted
to call it TUC, [FRENCH].
And the English wanted to call
it UCT, Universal Coordinated
Time.
And they couldn't agree.
So they came up with this
other acronym, UTC, which
doesn't actually mean anything.
But we know
basically what it is.
And here's the gist of it--
so UTC is managed by the time
division of the International
Bureau of Weights
and Measures, which
is a building outside of Paris.
And the time division
basically is a bunch of people.
And what they do
once a month, they
get all of the national
clocks around the world
at an appointed time,
at the same time,
to realize one second.
And all that data they collect,
and they put it through what
they call "the algorithm."
This is what the director of
the time division called it,
the algorithm.
And they sort of average
it out to create what
you call a "fancy" average.
And they take into
account, like, oh,
maybe that clock hasn't been
performing too well lately.
We'll weight it a little
differently this time.
There's a lot of human
thought that goes
into creating this average.
And so creating
this time, creating
this kind of perfect second,
this now, actually takes time.
Figuring out the ideal
length of a second
that they gathered last
month takes about six days.
And what they have
at the end of it
is actually really
kind of the best clock.
It's the best possible
average of all
the best possible realizations
of seconds in the world.
And they take that,
and they relay it
back to the national labs around
the world to synchronize to.
And so if you're wondering what
the best clock in the world
looks like, it looks like this.
The best clock in the
world is a newsletter.
It used to be a
paper newsletter.
It is now an email.
It's called "Circular T."
It's a document that the Time
Bureau sends out once a month,
where they basically assess all
those seconds from last month.
And they tell you how fast
or how slow your second seems
to be compared to this fancy
average that they've created
and how you might
maybe slow down
a little bit for next month
or speed it up a little bit.
So in a sense, now
doesn't really exist.
It's like it used to exist,
and it's going to exist,
but it's always in the
process of becoming.
And the director
of the Time Service
described this universal
coordinated time to me
as a post-real time
process, right?
It's always kind of
cooked up after the fact.
It's manufactured.
And the same kind of thing is
actually going on in our brain.
We are bombarded by
different kinds of data
all the time coming at
us at different speeds,
both externally and internally.
And your brain is
trying to kind of judge
from all this input
arriving at different paces,
like, when it all began, where
it kind of originated from.
What was the now that gave
rise to these different kinds
of data?
So if I flash two flashes
to you at the same time
and one is bright
and one is dim,
the bright one is going to
reach your visual cortex
about 80 milliseconds
before the dim one is.
And yet you still perceive
those as simultaneous.
You don't perceive any
kind 80 millisecond delay.
So somehow your brain
knows that those two--
even though it's getting
two delayed signals,
somehow it knows that those
two things belong together
originally.
And it's going to call that now.
And this kind of
happens all the time.
If I see somebody
talking across the room
and I see their lips moving
and I hear their voice,
it's all synced up, right?
And that's actually
true as long as they're
within about 100 feet.
Because beyond 100
feet, the delay
between the sight
of their lips moving
and the sound is more than
about 80 milliseconds.
And after that, then
I notice the delay.
It's easier actually to see
with a car door slamming
across the street.
And it's like this
80 milliseconds is--
it's like our maximum tolerance
for things being out of sync.
If you're watching
TV and the signals
go out of sync beyond much
more than a 10th of a second,
you will notice it, and
you will be annoyed.
But what's interesting is
that babies, it turns out,
have a very
different experience.
You can show them a
set of moving lips
and have the voice
that matches it,
and you can move those
apart by 2/3 of a second.
The lips can open and
close before they even
hear the sound.
And as far as the baby is
concerned, it's all one event.
They live in this very long now.
It's very forgiving-- what
belongs together out there
and what doesn't.
So I want to just
take a break here.
Not a break, but there's a--
oh, yeah, so the
brain is actually
working really hard to
create this sense of a now,
and it's trying really
hard to hide the work
that it's doing from you.
But it's not perfect.
So there is this illusion
called the flash lag illusion.
And the way it works
is there's this--
imagine there's a ring
moving across the page.
And at some point--
or across the screen.
And at some point
there's a flash
that fills the interior of it.
And the flash keeps going.
But that's not
actually what you see.
You see this.
You see the ring as if it has
somehow moved past the flash.
And I'm going to show you.
There's a really short video
that will show this to you.
This works in sort
of different forms.
So you've got a
moving cube, and it's
going past a stationary cube.
And they are
theoretically aligned.
But I don't need to talk.
It's explaining
everything for you.
But you never see them
as aligned, right?
The moving one always
seems to be a little bit
past the stationary one.
And the reason this happens is
because your brain actually has
two ways of looking at objects.
It has a separate
system, basically,
for tracking stationary
and moving ones.
And actually-- so if
you're going and running
for a pop fly, you're running
and going after that ball
and observing it basically
using motion vectors.
Really at no point
are you stopping
to think, where's
that ball right now?
Where's that ball right now?
That's a question that your
mind really doesn't often ask.
Imagine a frog that had to ask,
where's that fly right now?
Where's that fly right now?
It wouldn't get very far.
So what's happening here is
as the ring moves across,
the flash is suddenly
asking a question
that your brain had
not been asking before.
You're watching the ring
with motion vectors--
yeah?
Wrap it up?
SPEAKER: Five minutes.
ALAN BURDICK: OK.
You're watching it
with motion vectors,
and suddenly it flashes.
And your brain has to ask,
where's that ring right now?
And the only way it can do
that is in the past tense.
It waits a little
bit, and then it
tries to gather
all the information
that it can within about
an 80-millisecond window.
And it decides
where that ring was.
And the reason it
gets it wrong is
because it knows
where the flash was,
but it's still
gathering data even
as that ring continues to move.
And that additional
data basically
biases your
perception of the ring
and the direction of its motion.
Well, I want to leave you
with one more thought.
And because our sense
of now is manufactured,
it's also very fungible.
And psychologists really
love to do experiments
that sort of tease this out.
So if I show you a sad face
for a second on the screen,
and then I show you a happy
face for a second on the screen,
the happy face
will actually seem
to last a little bit longer.
If I show you an
angry face, that one
will seem to last a
little longer, too.
And that's because,
for various reasons,
our emotions seem to alter our
sense of duration of how long
things last.
But it's more
complicated than that.
Because if I do that experiment,
if I observe that experiment
and I put a pencil
between my teeth,
the effect totally goes away.
And the reason is because,
now, all the time as we
interact in real life, we are
mimicking each other's gestures
and facial movements.
If you watch two people
eating lunch together,
if they're good friends, pretty
soon they'll fall into sync.
And they'll smile
at the same time.
And they'll raise their
cup at the same time.
And this seems to be a pretty
basic expression of empathy.
And even if I show you a
series of faces on a screen
so quickly that you
don't notice them,
if a smiling face comes
up, you will smile too.
And what seems to be
going on, as we interact
and as we have
that experience, is
that we are stepping into
basically the other person's
skin and trying to adopt
their rhythm, too, right?
So the reason that
the effect goes away
when I put the pencil
in between my teeth
is because I can no longer mimic
the smiling or the angry face
that I see.
And because I can't mimic it,
I don't experience their kind
of distorted duration of time.
And this is, again, kind
of an essential aspect
of our sociality.
We are stepping in and
out of each other's skins
all the time.
And it has been
asked, well, what good
is it to have such a
fallible clock, a clock
that you can kind
of bend so easily?
And the better question really
is to ask, what it does for us?
And that is that our
slightest social exchanges
and our glances and
our smiles really
gain their strength
from our ability
to synchronize them
amongst ourselves
and to kind of know gesturally
when the other person is,
when now is, right?
We bend time to make
time with each other.
So just to circle back
to what I said earlier,
you can have clock.
But you can't have just one.
And now all of us, really
each of us, is a clock.
We are the sum of our cells, the
sum of our circadian rhythms.
We are a consciousness going
around saying, now, now, now,
your now.
We're trying to
figure it all out.
And what I want you to think
about is as you look around
and you think about the clock
that's sitting to your left
or to your right
is really what you
are sharing in the most
literal sense is now.
And in that sharing you are
creating a bigger clock.
You are creating something
even bigger than yourselves.
Heidegger said, "this
time now as I look
at my watch, what is this now?
Am I the now?
Is every other person the now?"
Yes, but really that's half
the story, because we together
are the now, too.
My now is over.
Now it's your turn.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: In the study
about the babies,
how do they tell that their
perceptions are delayed?
ALAN BURDICK: They
use eye trackers.
And they basically--
they can have
a baby watch a pair of monitors,
one with a set of moving lips.
And first they
watch it silently.
And then they watch
it with sound on.
And they are
simultaneously watching
another set of
lips that is saying
something totally different.
And then suddenly
the sound comes on,
and they look to
see which screen
the infant is looking at.
The infant is basically trying
to match the sound that it's
suddenly hearing with one
of the two sets of lips
that it's seeing.
And they can pretty quickly
tell using eye trackers
which one the baby picks.
And the baby typically
always picks the right one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm interested in
the process you
took to portray in the book.
And since this was kind
of more of your definition
and exploring your
exploration of the now,
how did you decide who to seek
out and what sources to use?
And it says you went to--
going to the Arctic
and going to Paris.
How did you take all of that and
put it together into the book?
ALAN BURDICK: It
took a long time.
It took about 10 years.
There was a lot that I left out.
And one of the
things that happened
in the course of this book--
I actually started this
book about six weeks
before my kids were born.
And I have twin boys, and
they're now 10 years old.
And in the process,
in that 10 years,
I started watching
them as they got
older kind of grow into these
different aspects of time.
And simultaneously,
I'm kind of coming
to grips with the
concept of being a parent
and what that means in
terms of responsibility
and my own relationship to time.
And so that arc is really
the sort of container
that everything else
is contained within.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So for me, and
probably for everybody,
the now is like it continues.
And what I understand
from your talk,
you say is that time's
actually-- we perceive time
as snapshots, which are
about 10ths of a second.
So does this mean that we think
in the snapshots, like a CPU,
like, every cycle
has some operations?
So does the brain
work in this way?
Does it work in a snapshot
way, like a discrete way?
ALAN BURDICK: I mean,
there's a school of thought
that thinks that.
And the kind of
question is, like,
is time sort of going
by us, and we're
looking out a train window,
and it's just passing by?
Or are we sort of planting
our window on the world
and making it kind
of chunk that way?
And that seems to be
more of what's going on.
But it's not necessarily
a strict 80-millisecond
or 10th-of-a-second unit.
And there's certainly
no regular beat to it.
It's definitely not like
film going through a camera.
These kind of still frames that
you add up and then speed up,
and it suddenly
seems like motion.
SPEAKER: Most of us here have
had some mathematical training.
And I think it would be
easy to be kind of facile
and say, well, a time is
of zero, infinitely small.
Points don't have any dimension.
And I think what you've shown is
that that's not really the way
it is with human beings, right?
ALAN BURDICK: Yeah.
It's almost circular.
We can't perceive an
indivisible moment.
So what we call now
must have some duration,
however you want to measure it.
And really, almost
by definition,
that duration is the
length of the thought
that we spend thinking
about it, right?
SPEAKER: Let's thank Mr. Burdick
for coming here and talking
to us on this rainy day.
ALAN BURDICK: Great.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]